(tintements métallique
♪ ♪ ♪
- Inconnu du grand p y y y y y a
à peine un an, le pensionnat
pour Autochtones de Kamloops est
aujourd'hui trislelelelelelelel5
enfants y ont été découvertes,
l'endroit es s s s s synonyme
d'un éveil brutal. À Kamloops os
un peu partout au Canada,
impossible désormais d'ignorer
L'ancien r r r r r r r r r r rs
oublier les sévices et les
tentativililililililation.
Encore aujourd'hui, plusieurs
membres de la communautémemememe
les pieds, explique Rosanne
Casimir. f f f f f f face-à-face
a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a aa
beaucoup à cette pièce
e e e e e e e lui demandera
formellement de présenterdes ex.
R R R R R R Représentante de s,
mais aussi des Premières Nations
de Colombie-Britannique,
depuis des mois à rencontrer
le pape. Fille et petite-fille
de survivantes de ce même
pensionnat, elle sait
que l'audience ravivera
de profondes blessures.
- Pour notre chemin ensemble...n
Richard Smith et cinq autres
pagneront
la délégation. Même si l'Église
catholique canadienne a déjàr,rs
attendues de la part du papevvve
particuliè
archevêque d'Edmonton
- Àseseseseseseseseses,
j'entends de la part des peuples
indigènes le sentiment que :
"I"I"I"I"I"I"I"I"I"I"I"I"I"I"I",
je m'excuse" pour faire avancer
- Le chef de l'Église catholique
saura trouver les bons mots,itie
surtout que le Vatican u u u u e
iririririririririrectement ce qe
veut dire la réconciliation
en action. Tendre la main
enererererererererer, discerner
ensemble, marcher ensemble.
- Mais dans la communauté
de Tk'emlups te Secwepemc,
d'éventuelles excuses du pape ne
réjouissent pas tout le monde.
L'acte de contrition a
des décennies trop tar
selon l'ancien chef
Shane Gottfriedson.
Tout juste arrivé à Kamloops
y y y y y y y y y y y y y y y yh
estime lui aussi que l'Église'es
traînée les pieds avant
de reconnaître ses torts.
Peut-être qu'une visite
eueueueueueueueueueueut-être que
sur place du pape rendrait
ses excuses plus convaincantes.r
à se rendre à Kamloops.
Elle souhaite que le chef
de l'Église catholique visiteeùs
les 215 dépouilles.
La cheffe Casimir voudrait
s'adresser à l'ensemble
cocococococococococococommunaut,
mais surtout qu'il prenne
le temps de les entendre.
Les découvertes faite
et lancé un mouvement sansécécée
la vérité sur les anciens
pensionnats. Dasasasasasasasasar
souhaite maintenant commencer
à les soigner.
le chemin vers la guérisonseses,
mais elle y croi